وسطوني حتى يقبل يعني اثناء
المحاكمه ورفض ووسطوني حتى يقابلوه وايضا
رفض بشده
ووصلوني حتى
يتكلموا معه يعني
بعد النطق بالحكم وايضا رفض وطلبوا من عند
الامريكان بيوم يعني قبل الاعدام ساعات
انه يتحدث مع عائلته واذا رفض
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم اقدم اليكم حلقه جديده من برنامجكم
الذاكره السياسيه نتابع فيها مع الدكتور
خليل الدليمي وهو رئيس هيئه الدفاع سابقا
عن الرئيس العراقي الراحل صدام حسين اهلا
بك معنا دكتور خليل مره جديده كنت تتحدث
في نهايه الحلقه الماضيه عن العرض الذي
تلقيته من احدى القيادات العسكريه
الامريكيه فيما يتعلق بمغادره صدام حسين
العراق مقابل الدعوه دعوته لايقاف القتال
ما يعني البنود الاخرى في هذا العرض التي
لم نذكرها في الحلقه الماضيه عندما ذكرت
لي الفحو والطلب
سالتها قلت لها هذا يعني رساله من
البنتاغون من اي جهه قالت لي من كل الجهات
يعني من البنتاغون من سيايين من الاف بي
اي بيت الابيض من كل المتفقين اصحاب
القرار متفقين على رساله يكتب خطيده تطلع
انت بالاعلام تقراها مقابل هذا طبعا يطلب
من القوات
نعم
مقابل هذا يخرج الى احد ثلاث عواصم عربيه
اخترناها واتفقنا معاه في هذه العواصم
الاردن مصر دول نعم نعم مصر قطر الاردن
مصر قطر مصر قطر عرضوا عليك عرض شخصي لالك
نعم وايضا اني اذا اقنعته
ممكن يعني اكون معها يعني اخرج انا
وعائلتي
وجيبي متصل مثل ما يعني حكوا جيب متصل
بالخجين العراقيه وما عندي مشكله واي واحد
يريده
نعم اي واحد يريد الرئيس يخرج معه يخرج
لكن يعتزل عمل سياسي بشكل نهائي والعمل
الاعلامي
اكدت مره ثانيه
ولرئيس ولمن يخرج الرئيس مثلا اغراءات
اخرى نعم وعرض اخر انه اذا يعني اقتنع
الرئيس اقنعت الرئيس يعني ممكن يكون يعني
يختار اي شخص اخر ونفضل ان تكون انت
يختارك في العمل السياسي نقدر نوصلك احنا
الى مستوى نائب رئيس جمهوريه نعم مقابل ان
تقنعه قلت لهم اني يعني هذا الطلب مالكم
اوصله ويبقى الخيار اله بتفاصيل هل ذكرت
شيئا لك عن طبيعه المحاكمه عن المسالك
القانونيه نعم كانت تاكد على قالت لي اني
من باب النصيحه الطريق اللي ماشي بيه انت
يا استاذ خليل ما يوصلك للهدف اللي انت
تبغيه اللي هو الطريق القانون الطريق
القانوني نعم طريق معطل والمحاكمه نوهت
انه راح تكون صوريه والنتجاتها معروفه
الاعدام هل صحيح انه كان في قاده عرب
متاثرين جدا عند لقاءك بهم بحاله صدام
حسين في المعتقل
لنا ذلك واذا كان في يعني امكانيه لذكر
اسماء ايضا
في احد اللقاءات مع احد القاده العرب
الماء اوصف له يعني رجل كان يصغي ورد يسمع
من عندي ومده لقاء كانت 55 دقيقه كافيه
ادما كنت اوصف له الوضع كان متاثر جدا
واكد لي امام مدير مخابراته وامام نائبه
انه الرئيس صدام حسين والعراق كان سد
البني عن بين الدول العربيه وبين الفرس
وسيعمل هذا القائد العربي كل ما بوسعه
لاخراج الرئيس من هذا المطب اللي هو فيه
القائد العربي الاخر عندما وصفت له يعني
وضع الرئيس
وما جرى الى بكى ثلاث مرات
متاثرا بوضعه بكى امامك
ثلاث مرات يعني على فترات متقطعه خلال مده
المقابله بسبب احوال او وضع وظروف الرئيس
ايضا يعني كان يشيد بفضل العراق وفي اي
شخصيه من هاتين شخصيتين يمكن ان تسميها
نعم اللي بكى ثلاث مرات المرحوم معمر
القذافي كان متاثر جدا الرابع من نوفمبر
2006 كان اللقاء الاخير بينك وبين صدام
حسين قبل النطق بالحكم عليه
كان في لقاء له اخر اخير مع المحامين ولكن
منعت من حضوره اللقاء الاخير لك معه من
الذي حصل فيه قبل يوم النطق بالحكم كنت
متواجد مع زملائي في في المنطقه الخ ضراء
احنا طبعا يعني خلونا
احد بالقصر الرئيسي يعني قصر الجمهوري
هناك يعني المنام السكن
بيوم التقينا وياه التقينا بقاعه المحكمه
انا وزملائي كان الجو مشحون يعني بوضع غير
اعتيادي فكان يجلس على كرسي
واحنا نفس الكراسي اللي جالسين على طاوله
مستطيله انا وزملائي يعني قريب منه على
يساره
[موسيقى]
زملائي
كان يتصور انه الحاله متعمده فنبهنا
الحاله حاله سقوطها انه متقصدين الامريكان
انه جابها الكرسي حتى يصير يحصل لي اللي
يحصل اكدناه لانه هاي الكراسي اعتقد يعني
منشا صيني وهي اثناء الحركه يعني يصير
بيها يعني تحمى
وصير بهاللي صار
بعد ان غيروا الكرسي ماله وانتهى اللقاء
مدتها ثمان ساعات الا ربع كان يعني الجو
مشحون جدا شخصيا ما كان متوتر بس كان
حاسين احنا يعني لقاء الوداع هذا يعني
عارفين انه القرار الامور بدها تتجه بهذا
الاتجاه
نعم
يعني عاده اللقاءات يقسمها يعني يقسمها
بالمنتصف يعني
وزملائي وياه والنص الاخر نبقى يعني هيك
هو يطلب من المحامين من الزملاء ودعته في
هذا اللقاء او ما كنت تعرف انه اللقاء
الاخيره كنت اتوقع يعني احنا كلنا كنا
نتوقع انه اللقاء الاخير هذا
فاثناء التوديع
زملائي خرجوا بقينا انا واياه واقفين
فكانت يعني عيوني بعيونها يعني
النظر يعني متقابل
ونظرته اللي هي كانت يعني نظره مليئه يعني
الروح الابويه وهو يودع يعني ابناء شعبه
وانا اكون جزء من عندهم وانا نفس الحاله
قائدي يبقى هو رئيسي رئيس العراق
فكنت بذيك اللحظه يعني وصلت الى مرحله كنت
اريد يعني اريد الجانب الامريكي ياخذه
لانه ما اريد اضعف امامه
فبعد ان اخذوه جانب الامريكي وقبل يعني
وصولة للباب بعد ان عبر الباب اجهشت بصوت
عالي جدا بالبكاء وهذا اللي كنت دائما اني
ما اريده يحصل لكن الامور خرجت عن السيطره
والى ان يعني اجا الضابطه الامريكي وحاول
يعني اتك عليه ما كنت اريد انه اتك عليه
لانه هو سبب كل مصائب العراق
ناديت على زملائي واجوا زملائي وطلعنا من
القاعه طب باخر لقاء لصدام مع ثلاثه من
محاميه بدونك لانك منعت شو اللي صار فيه
باختصار ابرز ما حصل فيه
هذا اللقاء طلب طلب
ارسال ثلاث محامين وارسلت نيابه عني لما
انت لا كان يعني
مانعني يعني بعد ان
صدر حكم الاعدام
وراها بقينا بالمنطق خضراء
اسبوع كامل او اكثر من اسبوع يعني تقريبا
عشره ايام الى ان قالون الطائره امريكيه
تابعه للبنتاجون الى المملكه الاردنيه
الهاشميه حتى بدون ختم جوازات
الجانب الامريكي الضابط الامريكي المسؤول
عن يعني حمايتنا مسؤول مكتب الارتباط
جمعنا واعطى محاضره طويله عريضه يعني انه
قدمته كل ما بوسعوكم وما قصرتوا وبالاخير
التفت علي قال وانت يا استاذ خليل واثنى
كلام طويل على دوري وعلى اخلاص الرئيس
وعلى يعني اعتزاز الرئيسيه فقال لي من
اعتبار من اليوم
احنا حميناك حتى اجسادنا وحمايه قضائيه
وحمايه امنيه حمايه شخصيه من الان فصاعدا
لا نستطيع توفير الحمايه القضائيه من اي
يعني طلب عليك قضائي
او يعني
قضيه يعني ضدي ولكن نستطيع ان نحميك كان
مرفوع قضايا ضدك او كان عادي يعني بسيطه
كانوا يرفعوا قضايا ضدك بكل بساطه بكل
بساطه
وما الذي ذكره الرئيس الاسبق صدام حسين
للمحامين الثلاثه في اللقاء الاخير الذي
لم تحضره ثلاث مرات يعني اقدم على القدوم
ويمنعني الجانب الامريكي ومنع احد زملائي
ايضا هو نائب رئيس الدفاع
يعني من زياره موكله كان وكيل المرحوم
طاهر رمضان
فمن اتصل بجانب الامريكي وبعثت الزملاء
والتقوا مع الرئيس
تبلغوه بالمصادق على حكم الاعدام
فاكدوا لهم انه اني انتظر هذا اليوم وانا
متوقعه ودائما كان يقدرنا انه اني طلقت
الحياه من عام 1959 عندما ضربت عبد الكريم
قاسم انا ايضا حكمت بالاعدام ومحكوم عده
مرات بالاعدام فباب التاسع يعني استقبل
الموضوع برحابه صدر وبعد فيها رساله يعني
للشعب العراقي هي يعني رساله وداع ووصيه
بنفس الوقت انه لا تحقدوا
الشعب الامريكي ولا على الشعوب اللي اللي
اجت وغزتنا لكن الحقد او الكراهيه تكون
لقادتهم هم اللي سبب اللقاء الاخير مع
المحامين قبل ايضا هل عرض على صدام حسين
تناول مهدئات بعد صدور الحكم نعم وكان
يرفض يعني كان يرفضات رجل يعني مؤمن بقدر
بعد ما طلب الرئيس ووضع وضع خطه ركن يعني
القوه فوج لتحرير او قوه اي قوه فوز
لتحريره مشغله المطار مشغلات المنطقه
الخضراء القضاء عليه خطه كامله متكامله
وتمنقل المعدات الى القريب يعني على
الموقع اللي هو فيه طلب مني ان يعني انقل
هاي الخطه
النائب المرحوم عزت ابراهيم
ليضع يعني لمسات عليها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا مشاهدينا الكرام الى هذه
الحلقه من الذاكره السياسيه نتابع فيها مع
دكتور خليل الدليمي رئيس هيئه الدفاع
سابقا عن الرئيس العراقي الاسبق صدام حسين
اهلا بك معنا دكتور مره جديده
اعدام صدام حسين هل حضر ضباط مخابرات
ايرانيون نعم
كم كان عددهم لماذا
اثناء صعود الرئيس الله يرحمه على يعني
الدرجه وصاعد على المنصه اتكلموا حتى
يثبتوه لانه احنا اللي حاكمناك تكلموا
بالفارسي حتى يوصلوا لرساله انه احنا اللي
حكمناكم الامريكان
يعني عقابا على حرب الثمان سنوات
بالفارسي تقول بالفارس نعم كان حدا عم
يترجم له يعني لا لما حيترجم له بس هو من
الغايه كان اسمه اللغه الفارسيه حتى لو
بدون ما بدون
ترجمه
باللغه الفارسيه خلص انه ايرانيين موجودين
واللغه الفارسيه معروفه هل فعلا حضر قاسم
سليماني اعدام صدام حسين لا اعتقد
من صور الاعدام مريم الرئيس وموفق الربيعي
وهل كان يقولان امور معينه يعني اللي صدام
حسين او لغيره النفق الرباعي كان يعني
يشتم بالرئيس وكان خايف هو نفسه
هل صحيح انه عدد عقد الحبل حبل المشنقه
كان على عدد صواريخ التي ضربها صدام حسين
على اسرائيل هذا ما نقل من داخل قاعه
المحكمه قاعه الادم
39 39 نقطه
على عدد صواريخ التي قصف بها اسرائيل
هل مات شنقا فعلا
كانت كانت عمليه اعدام عمليه غوائيه
يعني انت تؤكد لنا الشكوك حول
موته شنقا نعم عمليه غوائيه عمليه اداما
من الاطلاق الشعارات الى التهديد الى اخر
مرحله
هو الذي رفض فعلا وضع الكيس نعم
عندما تقول غوغائيه يعني تتجاوز الشنق
هكذا تفسر
ماذا كان دور الضباط الايرانيين
ايصال رساله انه احنا اللي عدمنا نعم
في معلومات تقول انه كان عندهم اهداف اخرى
متعلقه بالتاكد من هويه من يقومون باعدامه
ربما
يعني اخذوا مثلا
اشياء معينه من جسده للدي ان اي للفحوص
لا اعتقد
ماذا حصل بالجثمان بعد الوفاه
نقل الى بيت نور المالكي تشفين
في يوم زواج نجله احمد
بعد بعد الاعدام مباشره
كيف كان شعورك عند اعلان اعدامه
شعور اي عراقي وشعور اي عربيه لكن شعوري
كان اكثر لانه
حقيقه يعني عايشه الرئيس ثلاث سنوات في
اصعب اصعب مرحله مر بيها بحياته فاكيد
تولدت يعني علاقه اخويه ابويه بيني وبينها
يعني ما كنا نتمنى انه تتوج يعني نهايه
المطافي جهودنا بهي الطريقه هل كان لديك
معلومات عن مصير الجثمان بعد دفن
بعد دفن الجثمان
يقال يعني حسب ما نقل اليه تم نقله الى
مكان اخر لانه
احد المواسير اللي تنقل الماء
يعني انفتحت على القبر
واضطروا ان ينقلوا الى مكان اخر بطريقه
سلسه وبطريقه امنه يعني المعلومات او يعني
ما بدنا نسميها معلومات ولكن ما سمعناه عن
انه تم التنكيل بالجثه وسحبها من القبر
غير صحيحه
يمكن ان تنفي ذلك طبعا
يحرس الجثمان من قبل الاقرباءه فما كان
يسمحوا لاي واحد يطوله
[موسيقى]
الخروج خارج العراق
والمعلومات التي سمعناها عن ان رؤساء
اجانب ومنهم الرئيس الاسبق في امريكا جورج
بوش الابن كان يريدوا ان يرى مقيد عند
اعتقاله اقصد هذه صحيحه نعم لكن اعترضوا
عليها كانت تعيدها
واعترض عليها انه راح يولد نقمه اذا طلع
بالطريق اللي كان يهدف الى بوش راح يولد
نغمه ويولد يعني صخب وسخط لدى الشعب
العراقي
ويكبل القوات الامريكيه المقاومه راح تشتد
وتخسر القوات الامريكيه بس حضرتك كيف تؤكد
مثل هذه المعلومه يعني من
يعني هذه معلومه قد تكون حتى على الجانب
الامريكي السريه
ما ما يعني احنا معلوماتنا مثلا على
المحاكم عن
اليوم الاعدام من داخل المعتقل يعني من
يعني هسه شلون هسه الموجودين بالحكم بده
واحد يطلع اسرار الاخر نعم يعني
معلومات
ونتوثق من مصداقيتها هل تعتقد ان القوات
الامريكيه هي التي كانت تريد ان تقوم
باعدام صدام حسين ام انها كانت يعني كان
بامكانها او تريد ان تطلق سراحها ولكن
اسراع السياسيين العراقيين الجدد بتنفيذ
هذه العمليه هو الذي حال دون اتمام مخططات
اخرى القوات الامريكيه كان ما يعنيها
موضوع دامه اكملت المهمه اللي اجت من
اجلها ازاحه الرئيس بمفهومهم لكن بوش
الرئيس الامريكي كان عنده حقد شخصي على
الرئيس صدام
اللي اسرع بعدامه الموجودين الان يعني
المنظومه الحكم اللي اتوا بها الجامعه
الامريكي يعني اللي كانوا اللي كانوا
ولحوا
بالتنفيذ الاعدام
هل صار في محاولات لتحريره من السجن نعم
من الاسر يعني قبل بعد اعتقاله كم مره مره
واحده محاولات جديه يعني
جنود سابقين مثلا او ضباط سابقين ضباط
وقوات خاصه سابقين اعدهم هو يعني الرئيس
الله يرحمه عدهم وكان يشرف عليهم احد
القاده اللي يرافقني احيانا المعتقل
يرافقني الى بغداد وهو مقر يعني مو قريب
من الرئيس ومن الانبار
فالرئيس يعني طرحوا على الرئيس
هاي الحاله ونقلتها الى ووضع الرئيس خطه
لعمليه
عليه الخطه كانت محفوفه من مخاطر يعني انه
بعد اطلاق يعني تحريره وين راح يروح
الرئيس يعني راح يبقى ايضا مطارد
نفدت بالفعل في مره من المرات احدى هذه
العمليات لمحاوله تحريره بعد ما طلب
الرئيس ووضع وضع خطه ركن يعني
القوه فوج لتهدئه وقوه اي قوه فوج لتحريره
مشغله المطار وشغله المنطقه الخضراء عليه
خطه كامله متكامله
وتمنقل المعدات الى القريب يعني على
الموقع اللي هو فيه طلب مني ان يعني انقل
هاي الخطه
النائب المرحوم عزت ابراهيم
ليضع يعني لمسات عليها
والقصد حتى يطمئن انه الخطه لانه عده
محاولات جرت لتحرير رئيس ولكن وراها ايران
لانه الايرانيين كانوا متقنين انه
الامريكان ما راح يسمحون باعدامه فحاولوا
عده محاولات
لاختطاف بحجه يعني انهم تابعين لفصائل
المقاومه
فاخبرت اني بهذا الموضوع قال يعني حتى
النائب يضع لمساته يعني بالموافقه اخبرت
احد ابناء عمومته يعني رجل كان من
المرافقين ورجل حريص على الرئيس ووفي له
وراحه يبلغ النائب وبقع عالق مده 21 او 23
يوم يعني له هو اللي يقدر يوصل الناب الله
يرحمه ولا هو فمن رجع يعني من رجع ايضا
وشع يعني اوشى بهذا الرجل وتم اعتقاله
يعني هذا الرجل المخلص اللي راح حتى يبلغ
النائب بموضوع
التحرير التحرير رئيس من ما قدر يوصل يعني
فشل بالوصول الى لاسباب
يعني يعرفها هو يعرفوها كثير من العراقيين
من رجع تمت الوشايه به وتم اعتقاله مده
طويله
العراقيين يعني اسباب لوجستيه او شو اسباب
تتعلق بماذا لعدم قدرته للوصول الى عدم
قدر يعني عدم
قدرته لاسباب يعني بعضها
خشيه النائب عن احد يعني ده المكان وبعدين
يرسل القوات الامريكيه علي يعني هاي احد
ابرز الاسباب فما اوصل
الرئيس العراقي الاسبق في مره من المرات
كيف سمع اصوات الرصاص وهو في داخل المعتقل
وتم ربط الموضوعين ببعض انه بعض عمليات او
احدى عمليات محاوله تحريره قد تكون هذه هي
انا يعني
الحديث
بعد يعني بلغني هذا الرجل انه ما قدر يوصل
وتم المشاهبيه يعني بلغت وتم اعتقاله
جيت بزياره الرئيس فليت الرئيس بضع يعني
صحي يعني يرثى له عيونه حمر منفوخات ووضعه
وضعه تعبان
فقلت له شنو القصه قال لي اني اسبوع كامل
كان يعني الامريكان صار لهم يلحمون يعني
يجيبون اقفال كبيره قال مشى ما شايفها قبل
قال بدوي يلحمون على البوب
[موسيقى]
اللي يطلع من من يعني ماكينه اللحيم بدها
تؤثر على النظر هو فعلا يعني
يشتغلون الليل كله ليل معناها ما كان يقدر
ينام ما كان يقدر ينام فقال واحد جاي يعني
اللي افتهمت من الامريكان هو حكى لي واحد
جاي ورامي يعني
المكان اللي انا فيه وعلى هالاساس يعني
الامريكان عملوا العمل ورا فتره اتصل علي
شخص من دوله عربيه يعني يغيروا الاقفال
يغيروا يغيروا اقفال احتياطات اكثر بس ما
نقلوه لا ما نقلوه
من كانوا يغيرون بالهاي وهو موجود
فاتصل علي شخص
يعني من المقربين قال لي الدوله العربيه
قال لي وصلت الرساله قلت لها اي رساله حكى
لي قال لي اني يعني بعث الجماعه
ورموا اطلاقات ناريه حتى تجس الجسم نبض
يعني هو
يعني سواء قاصدها او ما قاصدها هي قسم
الظهر البعير يعني هاي العمليه اولا نبهت
القوات الامريكيه انه هناك محاولات بعد ما
اجتمعت هاي القضيه مع القضيه الاخرى عدم
وصول هذه الشخص
المؤتمن من قبله الى النائب عزت الدورين
عزت الدوري الله يرحمها
الرئيس يعني
اختار انه عدم تنفيذ العمليه وقال يعني
بالحرف الواحد اني ما اريد اخسر اي عراقي
يموت بسببي
فاتركها وليديه تماما يعني نحن انتهى وقت
حلقاتنا ولكن كنت اريد ان اختم بسؤال لانه
سمعنا الكثير عن موضوع تقاضيك الاموال
الطائله من عده جهات بسبب مرافعاتك وتسلمك
قضيه الرئيس العراقي الاسبق صدام حسين
ماذا تقول في هذا الصدد
سالني مره احد الامريكان هو احد زياراتي
للرئيس الله يرحمه قال لي شدت قاضية قلت
له قضيت لان ما يمنون بالتطوع يعني عمليه
التطوع ما يمنون بها
المجتمع الامريكي والمجتمع الغربي قلت 200
مليون دولار قال لي قليل انت فنيت نفسك
وفنيت عائلتك قلت له هاي مقدمه فاكو مقدمه
اكو يعني دفعه اخرى دفعات قال بعد 200
مليون قال لي قديش يعني تقريبا المبلغ قلت
له يوصل المليار قال حتى هذا المبلغ قليل
مقابل انتفنيه عائلتك وفنيت نفسك وفي نيت
مستقبل اولادك
والعراق راح يحرم عليك يعني
انه انا متطوع
ردا على سؤالك اذا اذا انتوا اعطيتوني او
كل القنوات اللي قبلك اعطوني على هاي
المقابله يعني اموال فاني خلصت انا بقدر
ااكد للمشاهدين اني ما اعطيتك خالص ابدا
ولا يمكن ان اطرح ذلك
رئيس هيئه الدفاع سابقا عن الرئيس العراقي
الاسبق صدام حسين شكرا على وقتك وعلى كل
هذه المعلومات الله يحييك شكرا جزيلا
مشاهدينا الكرام لكم ايضا على طيب
المتابعه والى اللقاء في سلسله حلقات
جديده من الذاكره السياسيه
[موسيقى]